présence policière accrue recherches
intensives
la chasse à l'homme pour retrouver
martin carpentier dure depuis plusieurs
jours saint-apollinaire et sous les
projecteurs des journalistes de tous les
médias nationaux se sont déplacés pour
suivre les événements jusqu'à ce que
martin carpentier soit localisée mais
derrière ce déploiement toute une
population est sur le qui vive
kalt et police en avant legault ichi
pour loin là où jean la part de l'huile
les et robert olivier habitent sur leur
en bois joly dans les secteurs visés par
les recherches depuis judy gr août qu'il
retrouve stagnera pour retrouver
mouchetés un cap les chutes salazar mon
cas revient pour bien là on a juste hâte
que ça se place un peu plus loin sur le
même rang le quotidien de cette petite
famille est aussi chambouler pas très
beau
c'est sûr et death beloeil et l'homme a
finalement signé la belle a finalement y
élabore beloeil prête l'eau salée séchée
on sait qu il peut être appelé par deux
couillons la note rigaud doha plus près
de nous avec tous les enfants un peu
plus proche le soir lille ça soit les
portes soient bien barré c'est une
petite routine qu'on n'est pas habitué
d'avoir dans un rang qui réussit certain
que le plus les jours passent plus c'est
difficile
la municipalité a déployé une cellule de
crise pour les résidents ceux qui ont
besoin de soutien psychologique peuvent
se rendre à l'hôtel de ville où ils
seront pris en charge ce choses
abominables qui est arrivé ici puis ça
perdure donc pour certains citoyens
c'est assez difficile de certains
stressent que s'installe la population
l'abeille adema de famille n'est pas de
famille des grands pas comme moi qu'ils
quittaient qui veut pas me jeter dans la
tête quand les policiers les
journalistes auront quitté les lieux
quand la vie aura repris son cours
normal
les quelques 8000 résidants de cette
petite ville auront certainement
retrouver leur quiétude
mais jamais il ne pourra oublier ce mois
de juillet 2020 il se marie pierre
bouchard radio canada cette apollinaire